des poubelles qui s'empilent des rues
encombrées
paris pourrait bientôt être étouffé par
ses déchets la réforme des retraites
aura au moins fédérer sur un point aucun
secteur d'activité n'en veut les
syndicats des sites d'incinération
dénonce notamment le mutisme du
gouvernement face à une contestation qui
s'est généralisé depuis le 5 décembre
dernier
il ya aucune discussion aucun échange
aucune prise de conscience de ce qu'on
dit l'ensemble des organisations
syndicales mais bien un passage en force
du gouvernement est un système
antidémocratique
donc on verra si effectivement il va
jusqu'au 49 3 mais là on est bien
aujourd'hui sur un président qui est ni
plus ni moins d'un an on a plus
l'impression d'être dans une victoire
que dans une démocratie
les salariés sont bien décidés à
poursuivre le mouvement qu'ils ont
débuté il ya deux semaines même si cela
implique de bloquer le traitement des
déchets de 85 communes pas créer toutes
les conditions possibles pour bloquer
l'économie du pays bloquer l'économie de
nos employeurs voilà c'est aussi le but
de la grève dans les incinérateurs et le
rassemblement d'aujourd'hui
une grève qui perturbe l'élimination de
près de 6000 tonnes de détritus au
quotidien selon lagence métropolitaine
sic comme le volume de déchets enfouis
en un mois vient d'atteindre
l'équivalent de 60 % des déchets
incinérés en un an